so our next question comes from um
salia uh who says she's hitting some
style roadblocks when getting dressed
for work each day and she needs some
advice take a look at this
hi drew my name is belia i just went
back to work after four years for my new
job it is so important that i look my
absolute best i need help picking out
some key pieces for my new work wardrobe
i'm a busy mom of three my boys are six
three and one years old as you can
imagine i have no time for anything can
you help this mom out
[Applause]
[Music]
i cannot tell you how much that this
story personally spoke to me
after i had my two kids my body changed
i thought i was supposed to be a mom now
so like my hot pink nikes with my crazy
pajama pants like
were they me anymore and then all my old
clothes didn't fit and i i had a real
identity crisis and getting dressed was
honestly a little emotionally traumatic
yeah and so much changes when you have
kids it's because you know more than
anything like yes your body
physically changes
hair usually changes quite dramatically
most people lose there
um you know and then not only that it's
not really about you anymore it's about
the child you know what i mean there's
kind of all that time that you would
spend on putting yourself back together
is actually put into a child it's a
really emotional time for women i think
when i worked in a salon it was possibly
one of the most kind of you know
challenging times for a woman to kind of
re-identify herself in that kind of area
of how much attention she should give to
herself or not you know but really you
know you've got to feel good about
yourself to be able to give if you've
got nothing to give then you know it's
not coming from anywhere this was the
leah before
all right let's see her now selea come
on out
look at this glamour
how do you feel i feel amazing i love it
i think that's the best question to ask
how do you feel before i mean you look
amazing but how do you feel i feel
incredible i love the hair i love the
outfit dude you look like you run a
fortune 500 company
she looks like a boss
i mean
wow oh wow
do you know what the biggest
transformation was for me is when she
had her hair when she got dressed
before i don't know if you noticed but
your shoulders were slightly more
forward and you stand kind of taller now
which is nice
like you're ready to face the world i
feel great well that was my personal
revelation about beauty was being a kid
in a makeup trailer i would watch these
women walk into the trailer with like
their popped collars it was the 80s and
like their scripts and they would come
in like this and as the hot rollers came
out they would change their demeanor and
as the makeup went on they would look in
the mirror and they would walk out of
that trailer
with completely different body language
and energy and i was like
that's what beauty is
absolutely a feeling it's a posture you
feel like a different person it just
gives you like that boost
um i mean chris take me through what you
did here because it's just exquisite
well i think you know with the heels it
was always about having a little bit of
height but being comfortable a nude heel
goes with anything you could chuck them
on or everyone
a nude heel everyone needs i mean you
have no idea the tricks i do to make
these legs look long
so i mean how many inches is that um as
many as i can stand
as many as you can say well you make it
look effortless the way you've been
jumping around the stage
i did charlie's angels in these boots
wow oh yeah brilliant
like most women i'm trying to achieve a
longer look and a nude heel
perfectly does that and it's versatile
you know you can chuck it on with most
outfits the fitted dress but just being
a great length something that felt like
young but also comfortable and i think
that's a great sort of length sort of
hitting the knee and the jacket really
was just about making it making business
moves you know being professional and
again something that's best talent she
could wear with different outfits jeans
and t-shirt and that vest you'll look
like you're ready for the chanel runway
absolutely she does look like i feel
like she yeah do you feel really crazy i
feel incredible it was so important for
me to just
find the right key pieces for my
wardrobe to look my absolute best so
imagine going back to work after being
home for an extended period of time and
in the middle of a pandemic it's not
like you're out shopping and knowing
what the styles are finding the right
pieces is challenging it really is
because you're always thinking about
your children you're always everything
is for your children yeah well thank you
for just to add as well just so you know
everything was kind of we wanted to make
sure everything was versatile you could
mix and match so it's interesting like
you said earlier i'd love to see that
with jeans like the jacket would look
great with a pair of jeans and a white
t-shirt so we wanted to make sure she
could you know reuse the outfits and
make them more than kick off the jacket
oh here we go
and now she's ready for drinks with the
girls
do you find time to exercise diet do you
do anything to give back to yourself for
your professional career i don't
but i try healthy i'm honest i i don't
go to the gym or anything like that it's
on my to-do list yeah i might do this
but um i do try to eat right or you know
well you look like a good
whatever you're doing it is working and
i'm happy that's what's working yes i
love my kids and i'm so happy to be back
at work and being a working mom is such
an amazing thing yeah
well that is the message right there and
chris you didn't just bring your style
and wisdom for thalea today you are the
global creative director of color wow
and everyone in our audience is going to
go home with some of their products
[Music]